hey Gary Mike Matheny from share through
like when you talk about value and data
how much of the data we have access to
unlimited amount of data how much is it
that is a value is a hundred percent of
it valuable is it ten percent of that
data valuable I mean you know that weird
thing for me is is I don't I'm stunned
you know again I come from like selling
lemonade and baseball cards and wine so
now I come into and I have a lot of
clients at our CPG clients and I'm just
always stunned and you a lot of people
here are much more tenured and
understand this better than I do I'm
fairly new to the corporate world I'm
just stunned how many people forget like
what they're trying to do for a living
right like we just get so on these
tangents and it gets so inside marketing
baseball I call it you know we just talk
about our terminology I mean the data is
as valuable as you want to make it as
long as you actually understand what
you're trying to achieve so like the
clients that are most happy with the
work that I'm doing by producing micro
content for social networks are the ones
that are ecommerce like Green Mountain
Coffee they know how many K cups they
sell because of our micro content and so
I'm writing a new book called Jab Jab
Jab right hook and it talks about the
formula of like setting this up because
most of us in this room and in the world
are in right hook right hook right hook
right hook mode Oh ease pushing so we
need to find how to bring value I think
the data is super important but I think
we overuse data and I'll tell you one
thing I very much believe about data
data's post-game it told you what
already happened and I think we need to
innovate more on our intuition and start
using more EQ in this industry than just
IQ